[Musik]
soll man die WM in Katar boykottieren
darüber spreche ich heute mit dr Fedor
weiser einem Psychologen der sich
intensiv mit dem Thema Fußball als Droge
beschäftigt und jemandem der freiwillig
den ersten fC Köln trainiert also einem
verrückten herzlich willkommen Steffen
Baumgart vielen Dank Herr Baumgart
werden sie die WM schauen trotz aller
Kritik ja ich werde sie auf jeden Fall
schon nicht nur aus beruflicher Sicht
sondern auch Interesse dann direkt an
den Doktor ist das vielleicht schon der
hilflose Rechtfertigungsversuch eines
Süchtigen also ich halte die
fußballsucht für bei der
Nationalmannschaft sowieso eher für eine
weiche Droge es geht um Liebe um Hingabe
und Passion um Leidenschaft und der aber
auch mit der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft nichts zu tun das
sehe ich ihnen ähnlich ja das sehe ich
jetzt ein bisschen anders aber machen
Sie ruhig erst mal weiter das ist hat
man das denn dann im Hinterkopf die
Menschenrechtssituation trotzdem da die
Situation ist ja was die Menschenrechte
angeht in Katar ja schwierig ich bin
aber fest der Meinung dass man wenn man
was verändern will muss man vor Ort sein
aber jetzt ist die schlimmstmöglich
Situation eingetreten sie klingen schon
wie Uli Hoeneß
aber ich finde die auch nicht falsch das
Uli hoenes gesagt hat also noch mal muss
man auch mal sagen also es geht ja nicht
darum wer macht was falsch oder wird
richtig ich finde das sehr schön und ich
finde sie auch wichtig dass wir
diskutieren dass wir reden wie könnte
ich denn jetzt praktisch ich sitze zu
Hause wie kann ich mich davon abhalten
den Fernseher einzuschalten kauf dir
einen Hund
machen bisschen Sport machen man muss
sich anders erleben und spüren und und
überlegen was würde mir Spaß machen was
mit mir im übrigen Spaß machen und wenn
da nichts ist
dann würde ich mir mal Gedanken machen
was ich für ein Leben für
das geht jetzt hier eine ganz falsche
Richtung finde ich das Gespräch freut
ihr euch auf die WM in Katar nein so
eine klare Antwort oder ja ja können wir
den Kataris vielleicht subtil zeigen
dass wir nichts von ihnen halten indem
wir immer Timo Werner spielen lassen
[Gelächter]
die heute alle rum schreien guck
geschwindet anders sind die ersten die
im Fernsehen sitzen werdet ihr die WM im
kartabolkottieren
also kein Spiel gucken na keins wir
haben aber ihr könnt das Werk bei Cott
ja klar ja aber so ein zwei Spiele
werdet ihr gucken wer im Finale
Deutschland Brasilien aber ihr werdet
die WM boykottieren ja aber ein zwei
Spiele werden
ich werde sie insofern boykottieren wir
machen im Büro keinen Tippspiel das
haben wir jedes Jahr gemacht machen wir
nicht und ich werde kein einziges Spiel
anschauen
können wir vom DFB im puncto Katar
Rückgrat und Moral erwarten nee auch
nicht weil alles was überhaupt des
Managements von dem Vereinen ist es
korrupt bis in der Arsch Spitzen ja oder
Arsch Spitzen also falsch verstanden ich
werde mit Sicherheit kein Spiel gucken
können sie ihren Mann davon abhalten
dass er ein Spiel guckt die Größe wie
sie wenn es halt im Winter ist ist es
halt im Winter aber für mich der zählt
definitiv pro Sommer W bei im Winter hat
sie nichts zu suchen Punkt ja und das
mit den Menschenrechten ja genau wie
wäre es mit dem Kompromiss wir gucken
keine WM Spiele aus das läuft eins
kann man es reinigen WM in Katar nicht
mit mir und ich übe jetzt schon mal den
Boykott und gehen nicht ins Stadion zum
FC auch wenn es weh tut und damit zurück
ins Studio was alles klar ich muss jetzt
echt auch rein
macht's gut
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfonds alles
dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten